good morning
Millennials welcome back to the CH and
happy Wednesday hope everybody's having
a great wedness day it's Wednesday it's
hump day don't forget to hump someone
you love speaking of someone I love find
me
somebody hey ja how you doing doing
better now that I plug my headphones in
hi lter Deo I'm doing well happy to be
celebrating the day of hump with my
favorite swirly would you say with
someone you want to hump would you say
that no I hate to start off the show on
such like a negative sad note but I did
want to share a story that just like was
remind I was reminded of cuz like
humping like who do I love to hump Theo
d t and I've actually been really good
with my like Theo grief Journey but like
yesterday was like a really hard day for
me and I was on the pelaton and I did a
Jen Sherman class and we were just
talking about her she's the instructor
who had that beef with Christopher Nolan
like so funny and she's a toaster and
I've been wanting to take one of her
classes and for me like I'm really not
partial to different um instructors just
the playlist right no but sometimes the
instructors like if they're super chatty
no thank you but if if the chat is good
I actually instructors matter yeah of
course of course but for me music is
primary because if there's a song I
don't know it ruins the class like I'll
leave like yeah so I found this J
Sherman class it had you know John Mayor
it was a low impact ride and I was just
like recovering from being sick I'm like
Let Me ease into it John Mayor Andy GR
hmer um Vanessa Carlton and this Vanessa
Carlton song comes on and I was like hit
with a memory I totally block this out
when Ben and I when Theo was like
literally dying it was like a week it
was Thanksgiving weekend we had found
out the week before and Ben's parents
offered to watch Theo for the afternoon
they were like go do something so we
went to the Jet game right we ended up
like being miserable and like not being
able to think about anything else and
left after 5 minutes but on the way
there like in the car ride it was just
like dead silent and we were like
miserable looking at each other and Ben
wanted to put on the radio and I'm like
please do not put on music I feel like
it's going to make me Cry he's like no
we'll put on like something good and so
this Vanessa Carlton song came out I'm
like okay Vanessa Carlton harmless right
it was the song Ordinary Boy now if you
listen to the song Ordinary Boy through
the lens of someone whose dog is dying
like you will seriously kill yourself
like no even just the title anything
with boy just a boy just an ordinary boy
but he was looking to the sky and like
Jackie so I told toally forgot that like
the song made me cry in the car and like
I turned it off and I haven't listen
like heard that song since then and it
came out in The Paton I'm literally in
the gym like it's like a full gym like
with people in it like sobbing on the
bike like so cliche like exercising and
crying but oh my God it just hit me and
then like my whole day was ear and I
couldn't stop thinking about the other
whole day dude well it's good to get the
grief out and it's also good when you
have days where you're able to push past
it but sometimes you just have to let it
wash over you because if you suppress it
too much it'll come out at in weird ways
at weird times no of course but like I'm
also lowkey annoyed like that that song
is ruined for me that's such a good song
If it makes you feel better I haven't
heard that song in so long it's giving
like what's that effect Mandela effect
where yeah showing up keep showing up
but for me I get through that's not the
Mandela effect but yes I get through
life without ever hearing that song I
know but now I'm going to have to
actively avoid
it for the time being okay one day
you'll be able to listen to that song
and smile and I want to do the class
again and it will remind you of Theo in
a positive way yeah you know and you'll
be glad to be reminded of the do yeah so
that's what I've been dealing with how
are you I'm good super busy day
yesterday and we ended it with freaking
Fred which is our monthly patreon live
show yeah everyone's like Jackson Claude
you ever going to do a live show we do
now a monthly live show we hadn't done
it since last winter due to a lot of
things but now it's back it's monthly
and it's on patreon so we went live on
YouTube last night everybody was live
with us in the comments having fun we do
like an hourong show and it's a jolly
good show it's a jolly good show and
it's very different from the toast like
we have different segments different
games like it's really fun it's giving
like Watch What Happens Live energy it's
just like chaotic yeah and I loved it I
had so much fun and you can also like
you tune in live at 8:00 P.M but if you
miss it like you have to work or
something the link is still live you can
go watch it if you're a patreon member
um so it's just fabulous fabulous
fabulous yeah so that took up my evening
and that was really it for me so no
content updates not haven't watched
anything haven't read anything uh we
watched a little bit more of the OC
maybe like two episodes last night now
we're at the part where Seth is like
stuck between Anna and summer and it's
just unrealistic like he's been in love
with Summer his entire life and summer
finally likes him back and he's like
maybe I should date Anna now who's like
kind of desperate like even though I
remember growing up watching the show
hating Anna she was the villain she was
the villain because of her haircut like
she what kind of 16-year-old was walking
around with the pixie cut like seriously
she was just she was not for me now
watching back she really is a nice girl
at the end of last night's episode we
finally are introduced to Oliver and I'm
like I don't even like Ben is not ready
for the journey he's about to go on with
Oliver no he's not one of the worst
characters in TV history he's like the
Juliet of Gossip Girl he's the Juliet of
the OC he's
worse who do you think was the worst
villain in Gossip Girl Juliet Georgina
Georgina wasn't bad but Juliet
or um Ivy I think Georgina is the most
iconic villain of Gossip Girl Who
bothered you like crawl make your skin
crawl oh Georgina didn't make my skin
crawl Oliver doesn't make my skin crawl
he's like a great villain he is Juliet
and Ivy are just like weenies of the
week just trying like trying so hard so
desperate to like Georgina and Oliver
actually like exact
parallels they're already in that world
like they're not yes pretending to like
and they're just like Disturbed people
yeah yeah yeah that's so true actually
great parallel yeah but actually you
know the creator of Gossip Girl is the
creator of the OC dis guy Josh Schwarz
and there you can tell like when you
watch a show back toback like how the
same person made this show like there's
a lot of the same formats and structures
but just like East Coast and West Coast
yeah yeah like they I think they use
like a lot of the real places around the
OC like the South Coast Plaza like these
are real places same with Gossip Girl
like they would go to
the Empire Hotel like that's a real
place right right I like that yeah I
like it too it's a great job I'm glad
you guys are enjoying I want to know
Ben's thoughts on Oliver when Oliver
does Oliver things when Oliver does the
thing that he does the things yeah but
mostly like the one thing what's the one
thing pe oh my God yeah yeah like crazy
crazy that's Marissa though oh great
judge a character that's in my future
and I'm looking for forward to it that's
really fun why does today feel like a
Friday riddle me that I'll tell you why
because when you're Your Own Boss every
day is a Friday yeah I don't know why I
was just like oh you could watch OC this
weekend it's Friday that's like the vibe
I'm getting but you know what why not
treat every day like Friday if you can
so funny how like personal the days are
you know what I mean cuz for me like I'm
having Monday energy today cuz I have
been sick for a whole last week and
today is like the first day I actually
feel 100% better like I don't have to
wake up in the middle of the night and
take Advil like I feel so much better so
I'm like and I got dressed and I got my
haircut yesterday so I just feel like
I'm getting my personality back you know
like I'm feeling like myself again and I
like was walking to work with my music
and like yes Popp and like I just
it feels like a Monday like I'm ready
and I woke up extra early made myself
eggs I'm like yes pop off this
girl yes oh that's interesting my last
two days have been so jam-packed like
truly working until 11:00 p.m. that it
feels like that was a whole week those
two days so now I'm like fried Friday
Friday got to get down on Friday you
know what I'm just going to like live my
life as if today Friday okay wait I
totally forgot to tell you this because
Ben forgot to tell me this we get in bed
last night he's like oh my God I forgot
to tell you I was robbed yesterday I'm
like excuse
me now there is this and I want to share
the story because I need to warn the
girlies there's like a new scam going
around and it happened to me like a few
months ago me and Ben were walking in
the West Village at night and this young
girl came up to us and me and Ben worked
together we were two people she was one
she was like a young girl she like
wasn't threatening at all so I it didn't
register at the time that this was like
it was like a scheme that was becoming
popular within the schemer Community she
was like you guys like I lost my license
like I need to get back she named like a
random but a town I had heard of like uh
Ron cona she's like I need to get back
to Rona like can you have $20 and I was
like
no then Ben says he gets in bed
yesterday and he's
like I was robbed and I'm like excuse me
he's like I was kind of like emotionally
robbed I'm like what are you talking
about so Ben's walking to the subway
he's almost at the subway and he's
passing a bank and as he passes the bank
this guy and this is like a bigger guy
just Ben alone comes up to him and like
is very very close to him Ben said his
chest was like touching his shoulder and
was like oh I lost my license I need to
get back to Tom's River which is a real
city in New Jersey's like my wife's
waiting for me like look you can show
I'll show you a picture like I just like
I need some money and he like wouldn't
let Ben walk and he was like I just need
the money and like Ben was cornered and
Ben was like kind of freaking out and he
was like benen was like sorry I don't
have any cash and the guy was like oh
there's an ATM right there like so it
was kind of smart scheme they stop you
in front of the bank and Ben was like
all you know what the bank is actually
like full there are people in there like
nothing bad can happen to me in there so
Ben was like you stay here I'll go to
the
bank he went into the bank he took out
$40 and he gave it to this guy and left
and I was like wait what Ben was telling
me the story he was like honestly I
thought it was the the best way to get
out of the scenario like I don't know
what would have happened if I said no
and I'm like yeah I guess and I'm like
happy that you're safe but I'm like mad
on your behalf that you got swindled
yeah yeah no he wasn't just robbed
emotionally he was also robbed oh yeah
yeah yeah but he was like manipulated
into it wasn't like there was a gun or a
knife yet but like he was emotionally
manipulated into being robbed do you
know what I mean yeah well considering
like the actual robberies and theft SEO
on in the city like this was light you
know a light verion I was just happy
that he he was okay like people now are
riding right on scooters swiping
people's handbags you have to be so
careful this is a new scheme that's why
I wanted to bring it up like if somebody
tells you that they're lost and they
just need to get home like they're fine
right but how do you get out of that
situation like I know I was trying to
think I'm like okay so what could we
have done better next time for this not
to happen and I said Ben like how do you
walk cuz you how you walk in the city
like they're obviously choosing targets
and I'm sure Ben was like on his phone
like looking
around I walk like a linebacker like
I've got something to protect I'm like I
walk fast and hard yeah or you go into
the bank now that you know this is a
scheme you go into the bank and you like
go to a teller and you tell them to call
the cops so that's what I told Ben to do
but he was like you don't understand
like I had to get to a meeting like I
had the whole day like I'm like I would
have gone to the teller and been like hi
uh can you just pretend you're talking
to me there's a man outside trying to
rob me I'm going to stay in here they
have a button you know they have the
button under the desk like call the cops
or ask them if there's like a side exit
I know Ben just wanted to like get out
get clean and you know what he did the
right thing because he's safe and
unharmed and the only thing he lost was
$40 which like just killed me but it is
what it is interesting well thank you
for that PSA tury yeah if somebody comes
up to you in the street because and it
happened to me and the girl looked
pretty innocent I actually felt bad for
a second I was like wait she's really
lost and she need to get back to wron
con like I can give her $20 but she just
looked like there was a little something
Shady about her and that's like the new
thing the new scam is like I'm lost I
need to get back and they name like an
outer burrow and they're always and now
that I think about it the girl in the
West Village was standing in front of
this like Boda with an ATM they stand in
front of an ATM it's actually pretty
smart I was thought he was going to say
I have
venmo oh my God LOL but it's like if you
have venmo then like don't you have
Apple pay a metro card to get on the
train yeah but I personally I have been
mowing no Apple pay I don't use Apple
pay that's
insane I mean okay so yesterday I got my
haircut I don't know if I told everyone
last night I got my haircut and before
my haircut cuz my haircut was kind of
late I got myself a manicure so I didn't
want to bring a bag these are like girly
errands I don't need like a big tote so
I shove all my in my pockets I get
to the nail place and I don't have my
wallet I'm like do you guys take Apple
pay and they're like yeah and then I
realize and I like this nail place cuz
they let you tip on the credit card so
I'm like okay I'm all set here I texted
my hair stylist I'm like do you take
apple pie she's said yeah like how great
is that I didn't have to go home that
you need to get apple Peg you need to
get one card especially I mean you don't
live in New York and like in New York
when you get in a taxi you can pay with
Apple pay and instead of like going
through your bag looking for a $5 bill
or a credit card to like swipe and sit
there like an like it's really
kind of I can't believe you don't use
Apple pay I was just talking about this
on the patreon episode with Olivia about
Disney which I need to listen to I'm
saving it for my flight tomorrow because
I was saying how she just like
understood the Disney app and like we
were paying for Merch through the app
like licky split she taught me how and
then of course the two stores were I'm
buying the merch's store isn't on the
app and they're like do you have Apple
pay I'm like no and I'm the only fool
like with a physical credit card at
Disney like rumaging through my bag
looking for my credit card you're giving
tradwife like you're giving old school
tury you know the way to my heart is to
say that you you have to have one credit
card on your phone I know ballerina Farm
doesn't have Apple pay so I don't have
Apple pay I don't know she's like
extremely tech-savvy with her 10 million
followers you she is okay maybe I'll
just one it's also really good in case
of an emergency no I will also I'm I'm
going through something right now where
what are you going through I got a new
phone how thrilling it took me about a
week and a half to find the time to set
it up I it is an hour's long journey I
start to set it up I'm moving everything
over and then I move over my cell phone
number and they say can't complete call
Verizon well you just put in the SIM
card there's no SIM card it's like a
metaphysical SIM card come again like I
don't have a SIM card every phone does
you just it's it's a digital Sim like
you just have to like confirm confirm on
both phones which I did denied access
denied they said like try the Sim to
call Verizon no I didn't try the Sim so
then I'm like between two phones now I'm
still using my old phone because the new
phone doesn't have my phone number I
could do everything on my new phone with
Wi-Fi but I don't have sell service now
do me a favor after the toast try
switching SIM cards and tell me if it
works okay how do you get your sim card
out of your phone uh safety pin you just
pin it in and then you flip the cards
the old one to the new one and the new
one to the old one okay where's the new
one probably doesn't have a SIM card
it's on the side of your phone like take
your case off okay I'm taking my case
off this take your high contrast baby I
know and now that like Charlie's getting
older I don't need this case anymore
it's beautiful thing I have like a
really nice pany one waiting for me do
you see like the little hole Yeah you
stick a safety pin in it I have never
done that before in my life I've never
physically changed my SIM card that's
insane that's literally how you get a
new phone like what are you talking
about no it like transfers my number
Trad wife tradwife what are you calling
Verizon being like hey I got a new phone
no I've never had to call this was the
first time that things went right and I
feel like it's because I waited too long
to set up my new phone no cuz when I
ordered my new phone I order it for my
phone number like they know they just
know they know of course and that's why
like the SIM card makes it so easy like
you just switch your I'm just letting
I've never I've never done it I kind of
want you to like do it right now on the
on the podcast like just so I can prove
my point
I mean if Zach would bring up my new
phone it's been charging and a safety
pin and a okay that's going to be a
little harder or you could use your
earring I don't have one in it's what I
love about these headphones what I love
about these headphones is I don't have
to wear earrings and I actually put on
earrings for Disney because I wanted to
like you know enhance my face and be
cute and like they're so I find earrings
so painful and like annoying and I'm so
aware of them I can't wait to take them
off that's so funny I'm like a big ear
earrings girl I always have been and I
feel like maybe I talked about this on
the patreon I I think I used to wear
like big earrings all the time when I
was really insecure about my weight cuz
you felt like it would like distract and
like dazzle up and now that I've like
toned back on so much I wear like so
much less makeup and I actually don't
really wear big earrings anymore also
like I invested in one really nice pair
of diamond stud earrings and I keep them
in 24/7 so like I never that I used to
wear my diamond studs all the time but
now with these headphones and also when
I wear headphones and I'm wearing an
earring it like digs into me no you need
surgery so I I just decided I'm taking
out my earrings for my the sake of my
work but when you want to dress up an
outfit I put on an earring and I just
hate it like I wish I never got my ears
parsed how about that why didn't you
seal them up I did and then I got them
parsed again on the breath live remember
a live parsing with Alis and Lou yeah so
why did you reparse because I was going
to a wedding no a wedding your friend
Margo's wedding and my outfit really
needed earrings and I was like like
trying to like repierce it so funny that
you bring that up because my friend
Margot whose wedding you went to when
you got your ears pierced like a fun
fact about her and her sisters that they
never got their ears pierced I wish
excuse me excuse me pared excuse oh my
gosh you're like me and niku yeah yeah I
it's not for me also my ear piercings
are
lopsided oh from where we got our ears
parsed back in the day and then when
Alison L pierced my ears live on the
breath I asked her to go over my same
holes like to reinforce the lops side in
this oh that was smart of you was it I
should have got new duh cuz I didn't
really realized till after like I forgot
cuz I got them pierced so long ago I
forgot that they were lopsided and then
when they were re pierced I'm like oh
they're lopsided cool thanks cool I'm
wearing this enormous jacket if you're
watching on the video you can probably
see like that makes me look like a
linebacker it's 500° you really want to
be a linebacker today I mean I'm
literally a sports analyst okay by the
way you sent me this clip and then a lot
of other people sent me this clip
of that guy going in on Brock
pie so there was a segment on ESPN I
want to say first take first take um the
guy who went off is
named oh God like not me being a grandma
no for real after going in on me and my
SIM
card I should have saved it like a big
yeah and I didn't send it to you
because I think you I listened to it
while we were still on the phone but
this sports analyst is going in on Brock
pie and like I don't think anything he
said was anti factual it wasn't antia
but it was his name is Ryan Clark and
he's an ESPN like talking head and he
basically went on this thing being like
I'm it's like been the struggle of my
life this season to like talk about
Brock pie in the same sentences as Lamar
Jackson as Josh Allen as Patrick Mahomes
and he was just going off so he was
basically like in a more harsh way
saying what we were saying earlier in
the week and actually listening to his
take and then reading the comments made
me want to um take back what I said like
I actually listening to him say it I
disagreed with it oh listening to him
say it I was like way harsh Tai but I
feel you like you're not wrong but like
what do you want from Brock like Jackie
it's his literal like second year in the
league and it's the second time he made
it to the NFC championships like and
he's five years old like right okay give
the man a break it's not his fault Jimmy
Garoppolo got injured I was talking to
Zach about this yesterday cuz I was like
do you agree with this take that like
Brock isn't good and Zach said that he
is a
product of the team that he's on like
the Niners have the best players and a
not great quarterback because they
invest in really good players and they
use that money that they're not spending
on a quarterback on the rest of the team
on the Kyle use cheeks the George KD the
Debo Samuels yeah because Zach was
watching his show and and the guy was
talking about Debo Samuels how Debo
Samuels is the exactor of the 49ers he
gave this statistic and I just want to
say why I find it like a little
problematic if I may okay also Debo
Samuels is like injured and they don't
know if he's going to play on right
that's what they that's why they were
talking about him they said with Debo
Samuels they win 70% of their games
without Debo Samuels they are 8- n and I
just like need if you're going to give
if you're going to give me a stat no I
need percentage and percentage because
like what's eight and N in percent how
far off is that from 70 eight and nine
so you win one you win eight and you
lose nine I feel like that's like
6040 4 being the
wins right I just I need a percentage
percentage okay wait hold on so it's 17
if you win eight out of 17 games what
percentage is that okay 8 over 17 equals
x over 100 so 8 * 1008 divid by
17 47
47% versus 70 okay so thank you that
would have been really more impactful
that's funny no I agree like I think
when we're when we're talking about the
Niners like as a society we need to be
speaking more about Debo Samuel yeah so
Zach was saying
that Brock is a function of the team and
so ICT so I say why don't they invest in
a quarterback he said well one they're
spending the money elsewhere and two
like they're investing in Brock like
they think that he could be their
franchise quarterback like in time I
kind of love that I like it look what
he's done way look what he's done in the
first two years it seems to work yeah no
you're right and so I just want to say
though kudos to us cuz everybody keeps
making fun of us like we know nothing
about sports Yad y y we had a take that
was then regurgitated not that they
stole it from us like obviously he came
to the on his own that like Brock is not
at the same caliber y y he kind of like
said what we said in a much more harsh
way on a real ESPN show so the next time
you want to say that the toast is in a
sports cast grab a spoon and eat my ass
I just want to say I didn't know Brock
wasn't at the same caliber I learned
that from you I would have thought like
Brock on I was still living in last year
where he was Jeremy L right the thing is
last year was a fluke because he wasn't
supposed to be playing last year the
real quarterback jimy GR got injured and
then it was like oh the season's over
then this kid had his Jeremy Lynn moment
made it all the way to the NFC
championships and it was like this fun
thing and I guess you're right they
decided to invest in him instead of
going to the draft and getting another
you know great quarterback and trying
they or trade for someone like an Aaron
Rogers they are investing in Brock and
it's nice oh except apparently the head
coach of the 49ers tried to get Tom
Brady to come and play for them well
he's the exception of course and he's
from the Bay Area yeah no no no I don't
think that's a slate against Brock no no
no but then they'd be Super Bowls
lingers yeah but I don't know I just
feel like winning a Super Bowl with Tom
Brady it's like it doesn't count it
means less I completely
agree no I want these guys to prove it
for them like and I feel like they would
feel the same like because everyone
would think they won because of Tom
Brady when I think that they could win
on their own I know I just I really need
like I feel like Brock is so young and
when he messes up it's not for like lack
of skill or lack of talent it's like
nerves and anxiety and like mental stuff
I really I don't I wonder if Brock has a
woman in his life but I I actually do
think if he doesn't uh a good woman
would really um I think settle his brain
a little bit you know and a a good
toaster woman I think yeah of course no
of course and we have a lot of you know
really religious Christian toasters and
that's what Brock is definitely looking
for and so I I can recommend a bunch of
girls that I know um but also like you
know he lives with roommates like he's
like young I feel like he's not in his
like sort of like serious settle down
area he needs to settle himself I think
that's what he needs for real like I
think he needs to go on Christian mangle
like dead serious find like a really
nice girl who's not in it for the fame
not in it for the money they can well
actually it's probably hard to be a
Christian a football player cuz like
your games are on Sunday and like so is
church but I'm sure he has like you know
a pastor who he work there like
satellite Zoom Church yeah yeah yeah
those mega churches like they have these
amazing streams yeah just kind of like
freaking Fred right right ours is a
little more high quality than like you
know Hill H
H but you know similar similar and we
kind of do the same thing we like sing
and preach uming singing and preaching
preaching and singing I do think prie
needs a girly we need a girly for
party
okay and he by the way he's like
extremely handsome and no like you'd be
lucky to have him yeah he's on his way
to getting like a $500 million contract
like maybe not 500 maybe 300 but like
he'll be fine yeah yeah yeah okay well
I'm so excited for this weekend like
football is life I know what Danny rhos
was saying now like football is life
yeah we're g to have like a big BBQ here
Shapiro was texting I think he likes my
grill so we're going to grill here okay
wait also
I saw like because now I'm on conspiracy
theory NFL talk and you know the NFL is
like really doing everything they can to
make sure the Chiefs win this weekend
against the Ravens and I heard that they
hired like the ref that was assigned to
this game is like notorious for going
really easy on the away team which is
the Chiefs that's like his thing this
guy um I don't know if that's true
because again I'm new here and I was
just reading this conspiracy theory on
Tik Tok but it it'll be interesting
because like based on records and based
on everything like the Ravens should win
this game it'll be tight but they should
win I don't know I feel like the Chiefs
when they're at their best they win
everything yeah but like their record
isn't amazing this year and they've lost
like a big like a good amount of games
yeah okay let's get into the stories
because we do have some like football ad
Jason stuff and and we have deer
toasters because it's Wednesday true so
without further Ado Ado here are the
fast live stories that you need to know
and the fast live stories that you need
to know are brought to you by
Squarespace Squarespace is the
all-in-one website platform form for
entrepreneurs to stand out and succeed
online whether you're just starting out
or managing a growing brand Squarespace
makes it easy to create a beautiful
website engage with your audience sell
anything from products to content to
time all in one place and all on your
own terms so whatever your reasoning
might be for starting a website welcome
to the party it's 2024 like you need a
website and it needs to look good but we
don't need to spend so much money on
like you know agencies and companies
when Squarespace exists with fluid
engine which is a Next Generation
website design system from Squarespace
it's never been easier for anyone want
to unlock unbreakable creativity start
with the best-in-class website template
customize every design detail and
reimagined drag and drop technology for
desktop or mobile stretch your
imagination online with fluid engine
built-in and ready to go on any
Squarespace site you can easily sell
custom merch and create passive income
streams that engage your audience and
scale your brand you can design your
products and promot you can design your
products and production inventory and
shipping are all handled for you saving
you time and money there are amazing
fabulous assets that Squarespace
websites have to offer like those
flexible website templates get great
analytics blogging tools flexible
payments email campaigns so head to
squarespace.com for a free trial when
you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com toast to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or a
domain again that's squarespace.com
toast to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or a domain after
you do that free trial at
squarespace.com today's episode is also
brought to you by seed there's a reason
you trust your gut your whole body's
Health starts here and 61% of people
experience gastrointestinal disc Comfort
seeds ds01 daily symbiotic is a new
standard in probiotics its
non-fermenting formula is backed by
clinical trials and scientific studies
and delivers more of what you need where
you need it so it's not just a gut
feeling seeds DS1 daily symbiotic
benefits your gut skin and heart health
so
it's where great health starts in your
gut it promotes healthy regularity and
Duty quality supports provides relief
from occasional digestive discomfort
bloating intermittent constipation um it
also supports a healthy gut immune
function and response to occasional GI
and environmental stressors everyone is
obsessed with their gut you know
whatever their issues is a lot of people
have like gut related uh skin issues
obviously gut related digestion issues I
feel like gut is like the thing of the
moment now and it's really important to
take care of it because there are a lot
of health benefits especially for when
it comes to digestion like making big
soft duties and seeds DS1 daily
symbiotic will help you feel healthy
look healthier on the outside too it
promotes clear smooth healthy skin and
it may help smooth the appearance of
fine lines and wrinkles it'll help your
skin maintain a more youthful look so
it's safe effective and science backed
it's a broads Spectrum probiotic and
Prebiotic formula with 24 clinically and
scientifically studied strains for Whole
Body Benefits it's rigorously tested for
14 classes of allergens defined by the
efsa so listen to your gut with seeds
DS1 daily symbiotic go to seed.com toast
and use the code 25 toast to get 25% off
your first month that's 25% off your
first month of seeds DS1 daily symbiotic
as seed.com toast code 25 toast thank
you la you're welcome our first story
trailer news that's their couple name
right Travis and
Taylor trailer like does sound like like
a mobile home yeah not that there's
anything wrong with that but I don't
know if it's not like the most like
romantic couple name heard I've heard
Tavis Tavis both really not giving
romance okay let's think about like
Swift and Kelsey
swce
kft not great it's not great Taylor and
Travis
anyways New Heights dropped and oh I
meant to watch it this morning I forgot
Jason and Trav are talking about the big
game what's so crazy is that not only
are the biggest stars in the world
having a romance on the biggest stage in
the world but that there's also a
podcast component where he does the
podcast every week and like talks about
these things no no he's like we're
getting the tailored love story in first
person in real time it's really crazy
and honestly I love it I think it's so
great for the podcasting medium I think
it's so legit legitimizes us I love that
like they blew up and what they decided
to do with their you know Fame and time
was start a podcast like I love it no
but it's also wild that he talks about
his
relationship well of course and it's
wild that like she lets him and I think
it really I think for a lot of people it
makes them think about her previous
relationship and how private it was and
how that maybe wasn't her choice but
she's always been really private with
relationships even before Joe I I feel
like she always was that person but this
one just feels different cuz he's just
like America like America feels like
they own him like and also you can't
like put him in a box you can't tell him
to like be Co like he's not Koi
No Travis Kelsey what's the symbol for
equals with a slash between does not
equal
Koy Travis Kelce does not equal Joe Koy
that's
true yeah anyways they're talking about
Bill's Chief's game Travis said that
Taylor absolutely loved meeting Jason
after Kylie told Jason to be on his best
behavior so in a new episod this was
confirmation that those two had never
met which is kind of crazy Jason and
Kylie had never met Taylor I assumed
Kylie hadn't but I thought maybe Jason
has right but no in a new episode of
their podcast I guess he's been working
all season you know not traveling taking
stuff seriously uh they reviewed the
game where the Chiefs beat the bills and
debriefed Jason's multiple viral moments
from the evening so Jason said quote I
wanted to take everything off and be out
there with the fans he said he had been
wanting to go outside and quote take my
shirt off and be out there I feel like
taking your shirt off is a Buffalo Bills
thing I wanted to take everything off
and be out there with the fans it is a
Buffalo Bills thing like those fans are
insane as for what kind of impression it
made on Taylor who joined Jason and his
wife Kelsey in the suite uh Jas uh
Travis said that taaye said she
absolutely loved you he said your best
first impression is the worst impression
ever
they also uh the shirtless Antics had
been discussed between Jason and Kylie
before the game took place he said I'm
not going to lie I gave Kylie a heads up
the moment we get into the suite I said
I'm taking my shirt off and jumping out
of that suite and she said Jason don't
you dare but Travis said once a Kelsey
man's determin there's no
stopping him Jason said she was already
telling me to be on my best behavior cuz
we were meeting tailor so she's like do
not be on your best behavior I was like
Kylie the first day I met you I was
blackout drunk and fell asleep at the
bar and then uh he said this is part of
the charm this is part of the Jason
Kelce charm I want to make my best first
impression and then Travis also said
that he wanted to see more Kylie content
from the game he said there was not
enough cameras on The Suite where you
can see Kylie I wanted to see her
reaction to all of that so bad no it's
true like I needed like a full 360
camera everyone kept moving around like
that's the thing about a suite it's like
your seat is not really your seat you
get up you get a drink you get a snack
someone takes this sh you take another
one like it's lowkey annoying cuz even
though everyone complains like oh they
only show Taylor so many times like it
wasn't enough yeah and I think Kylie was
wanting to be lowkey so we didn't get
all the reactions she stayed in the back
but Jason said I don't think she was
happy about it to be honest with you but
I think for Kylie that's just a day in
the life of Mrs Kelsey I agree like I
don't think she's actually mad she
married a football player like that's
what they do no and it's also always the
wife everyone else like thinks the
husband's behavior is like so funny it's
always the wife who's going to be like
oh my gosh my husband you just said a
mouthful their sister that's true
everyone's like oh how Charming to see
and the wife is like can we go home now
I'm going to kill you no it's like not
Charming when you do it every single day
you know when it's your reality it's
like a once in a fun time thing no it's
also like lowkey funny now we're like
pulling the veil back like I saw that
moment my and I thought to myself oh how
funny he just got like caught up in the
moment you know so much energy so proud
of his brother he's in Buffalo it's like
so many high stakes tailor here now
knowing like he planned on doing it and
like it wasn't this sporadic thing it's
like oh no I know why Kylie thinks he's
annoying like yeah he thought this out
loserville like not that he thought I
think he's a a very genuine person but
it's like when this sort of thing
happens in her life every single day
it's always the wife who's trying to
reign in her husband you know everyone
else can enjoy it I'm sure Ben does
things where it's like everyone's like
Ben's so funny and you're like can you
stop no actually
I but like Ben is funny but he's not
like the funny one in the relationship
like if you were to say like oh they
would say Claudia no no even like Zach
when he like tells all his jokes like
everyone's like ha this is so funny and
I'm like can you stop you're a better
example cuz your husband like makes so
many jokes yeah and for everyone it's
like it's so fun jokes all the time and
for me you heard this joke a thousand
times no for me it's like it's so not
fun jokes all the
time Jackie there's literally an episode
of Friends like that yeah they meet this
let me tell you please but even for you
it's like Ben's cooking it's like how
amazing like Ben Cooks first and you're
and we're like oh my gosh Ben cooked and
for you it's like can you stop cooking
no it's the most annoying thing on the
planet only because he doesn't know how
to clean like at the cooking yeah it's
nice to get a meal do you know how much
work I have to do afterwards you don't
even like the cooking no it's fine it's
good like tuna salad chicken salad no
but he did make me that crunch trap
Supreme oh right and you didn't talk
about it on the toast I didn't no
because you did so much content like on
IG I'm sure like you put it to bed but
you didn't even tell me like was it
everything you hoped for it was really
good like really good you need to have
him make it I'm going to we've been
sending like a lot of content back in
forth of things that he and I are going
to be collabing on and I'm actually
really glad that he did a test run on
the crunch WP Supreme because he learned
a lot the hard really hard part is
rapping it that looked hard and it it
wasn't an amazing rap but we now know we
need like smaller tostadas and the
biggest tortilla you could find
got it so we're going to have to do like
a major Publix
haul ring it up we're going to be
together so soon I was actually thinking
about that the other day because I was
thinking that you have a dog which is so
crazy cuz I don't and I was thinking
that when I come to your house I think
I'm going to like kind of pretend
Bruno's my dog I think Bruno should
sleep with me and everything like I I
would love that I know Brew would love
that and I'll of course walk him and
I'll feed it like I think he should be
my dog for for the time being that's
totally fine Bruno would love that he
loves anyone who's going to give him
extra love and extra scratchies yeah and
I haven't I hadn't you know thought
about where I was going to stay because
you know you and Olivia both run a a
good hostel a good bargain you know
no why it's free for me and I get
treated like a queen oh okay okay
understood and there's just so many good
options now it's of course easier to
stay with you because the studio is
right there and we podcast together but
like okay I could take the F minute walk
and you know take a golf cart and stay
at lives and I'm not GNA Li Olivia does
have better snacks than you she does I'm
just going to say that
um but then I remembered the Bruno
factor and I think I need to be near a
dog like I I really do like I think
living with a dog will bring me like
immense joy and I'm going to stay with
you for like two weeks so which whatever
works for you cuz if not then Satchel
stays with me yeah yeah Las noas it's
it's overwhelming the amount of like
really good options I have all
combinations and permutations work for
me so you what if I Olivia and then like
took Bruno with me is that an option or
that's like too crazy it's like I'll see
him yeah yeah yeah and Bruno loves
Adventure Bruno loves being over there
the kids like Michaela and Levi love
Brew so
all good okay even though brew and
Michaela like do have like ancient beef
oh because the one time that he pushed
her down she Michaela was what one and a
half she was like newly walking and
Olivia and her family like walked into
the house we were already there we were
so excited Bruno we ran to the door to
give them all hugs and Michaela walked
in and Bruno like jumped up on her to
give her love but they literally weighed
the same amount yeah and he pushed her
down it was Loki so funny no Bruno l
testing like new child Walkers like
really how how good is your balance not
actually I never said it
was um I don't know how we got so far
from the story but oh Super Bowl food of
course always it all comes back to food
so it went well the meeting of the
in-laws went well I need to I'm gonna
watch this episode they do this actually
pretty smart thing where they release
the podcast episode whatever Wednesday
whatever it is like early in the morning
so you can listen to it on your commute
or whatever but if you want to watch it
they do like a live YouTube Premiere and
it's always at like 9:30 which is a
little late um so I had meant to watch
it today so I could talk about it but
who is the time I know and I'd so much
prefer to watch it like I need to see
Travis's face when he says Tay I need to
see everything he also talked about why
Tay he also talked about why he did this
the heart yeah he said he like he was
pretty vague but he was like I was
spreading love because I the the Bills
fan had boot tail her tail her
oh yeah they had but so he said this was
about spreading love no way like
that's Fearless everyone knows that of
course no he didn't and by the way there
is literal footage of Taylor Swift at
the of of Travis Kelce at the Eros tour
when she sings fearless and then she
does that little spin thing and puts her
hands up and everybody else does the
heart hands he's literally like in the
booth with the dad putting his hands up
in heart hands like please of course
it's tailored inspired but he also just
made it like a bigger message of
spreading love
yeah always a good message yeah yeah uh
next story still part one of trailer
news which is that Taylor had a gno last
night with the sweet crew including car
delvine and Britney momes they went out
for dinner and I just have to say best
dress Mahomes stepped her up
Britney Mahomes best dressed that hair
the hair the fit the bag the everything
she looks like
like a star a million bucks a m yeah
yeah I I was that was my takeaway as
well she stole the show and there's like
Paparazzi video of them walking out we
saw all the pictures but it's always fun
to watch the actual walk from the
restaurant to the car and then like
seeing how the photos end up and her
hair is just bobbing in the wind I don't
know who the did her hair but it is
This Magnificent blowout that's just
Moves In The Wind it was so gorgeous she
stole the show who makes the fit like we
need all the details I was not expecting
that no 10 out of 10 10 across the board
I love this outfit for anyone and for
her I love so much no notes I wouldn't
change a thing not one thing and I think
it's interesting that they came back to
New York I guess they like can't this
week like they won't be like spending a
lot of time with the guys because
they're obviously like in major training
mode and the game is in Baltimore so I
guess it kind of makes sense that they
would stay in New York Patrick and
Travis definitely went back to Kansas
City yeah
and then it go with them yeah so no
that's nice that like Taylor's looking
after Britney I wonder if she stay if
they're all staying together they're
definitely not maybe she lent that
Tribeca Apartment that Sophie Turner was
using to Britney and the kids right oh
Britney has multiple kids two two how
nice Yeah the more I learn about Britney
Mahomes she's like this weirdly
polarizing figure the more I learn the
more I like I'm sorry no I like her she
and she's really like a regular girl and
that's why I think this outfit was so in
for so many people cuz she really always
dresses like a like a really cute girl
that you knew in college like she
dresses really young and fresh not ever
like super TR like celebrity stylist she
just dresses like a cool girl who shops
at aritzia it's like kind of relatable
even though her husband makes $500
million yeah and this was like a she got
a stylist and you know what like her
life has changed she's allowed and
honestly I respect like getting a Glam
Squad like a different like a an elite
Glam Squad I'm sure she got the hookup
from Taylor she's never been Paparazzi
like this in her life she needed new
clothes she went to buror it'sot like
I'm okay with it no and and she's still
the everyday girl cuz this is what the
everyday girl would do if in this
situation she got papered enough times
like in her usual wear and she's like
you know what I'm treating myself and
it's Britney's turn now yeah no I mean
she was in those paparazzi photos with
like Gigi Hadid Selena Gomez like sorry
you need a stylist at some point and she
didn't look B no but she didn't no no
but it's okay to ask for help no and and
it's like no I never saw those pictures
so I was like and I thought Britney
needed help I actually thought she held
her especially cuz all those girls
especially Taylor I don't think Taylor
has a stylist they dress they wear like
they does have a stylist oh yeah and
it's I feel like why do you know that
list height is always posting like oh
that she does have a stylist yeah it's
this guy and I think you really I I
don't like to blame stylus because
stylists work off of a person's
aesthetic and like you know no one's
really going to get into into something
they don't like their own personal style
is always infused with the stylist work
and it's like the one thing about
Taylor's like recent Renaissance and
like sh shot to you know this level of
stardom I don't think she ever dreamed
of that hasn't changed and it really
needs to like her her style is like the
one thing about her entire brand that's
not perfect everything else is perfect
the music is perfect that's why I
thought she didn't have a stylist and I
I I actually thought it was like I
thought it was kind of cool yeah that
like she doesn't think so hard about
those things no she has a stylist I'm
going to tell you his name cuz I was
going to say that group even though
they're like the biggest stars in the
world Blake Lively notoriously does not
have a stylist yeah but well you know
what Blake Lively has a sense of style
right Selena Gomez probably has a
stylist but I wouldn't say she's
incredibly stylish so it's like Britney
was was totally meshing with the group
and then she just decided like I'm going
to be the number one girl in this group
tiller's stylist is named Joseph Castle
Falconer and he posts like every picture
of tlor everything his entire work oh I
need to go look he has other clients too
like this girl I don't know her but
every other literally every single photo
is Taylor Swift and that's it Joseph
castle Yeah but he did do the aor
costumes cuz he seems to be posting
those like as if they're his own work
and the aor outfits were amazing okay no
no no okay so this I'm glad I looked
this up so she has a stylist when she
does like Big Red Carpet Events clearly
yes duh
does she have a stylist when she goes
out to dinner that's what I thought she
doesn't have a stylist for that's
actually a very good distinction cuz
none of the photos are like her street
style
photos um her street style seems to be
chosen by her but by the way he has
photos with Taylor you know I'm down in
2021 so he really is like a lifelong
partner of hers and she's never had
exceptional style really I think there
there are minute slays here and there
but there's nothing that comes to mind
that's like jaw-dropping yeah I like I
liked her most recent Golden Globes
that's like one of my favorites yeah
loved yeah here he is in 2020 like I
think this is her OG stylist and I kind
of love that she like sticks with the
the person who she likes her
style yeah but it it should be and it
could be better but she's happy with it
I I really respect that like not
everyone has to be like walking the
catwalk High fashion at all times and
that's why I like that it seems as
though and I'm going to continue to
choose to believe that like for dinners
and street style she picks out her own
clothes I think that would be
commendable too but I don't think that
it's but then why doesn't he post
pictures of her in the streets I don't
know I don't know but I think someone
helps her get ready because even the
outfits like that I don't love when she
goes out to dinner and stuff they're
still like styled like a normal person
can put on clothes and like look cute
but they can't really style an outfit to
perfection in terms of like jewelry and
everything like yeah JP to bottom yeah
but back to Britney slayed the house
down slayed the house down that's the
head line here they went out to dinner
Britney slay yep our next story and they
went to noo oh is that where they went I
was which one downtown cool our next
story Ryan Gosling calls out the Oscars
over Greta gorg and Margot Robbie Barby
snub saying there's no Ken without
Barbie so as we reported yesterday Ryan
Gosling was nominated for best
supporting actor for his work on Barbie
and Greta Gerwig was not nominated as
best director and Margo Robbie was not
nominated as best actress yeah so he
said he put out a statement thanking for
the nomination it's an honor to be
nominated but he said there is no Ken
without Barbie and there is no Barbie
movie without Greta Gerwig and Margo
Robbie the two people most responsible
for this history making globally
celebrated film no recognition would be
possible for anyone on the film without
their talent grit and genius he
explained to say that he's disappointed
that they're not nominated in their
respective categories he said that would
be an understatement Against All Odds
and nothing but a couple soulless
scantily clad and thankfully crotchless
dolls they made us laugh they broke our
hearts they pushed the culture and they
made history their work should be
recognized along with their other
deserving nominees I just want to say
before we get into statement like
Against All Odds and with nothing but a
couple hundred million dollars yeah just
like let's just clear that up simu Leo
also tweeted like everyone's being you
an ally um I saw a tweet that I actually
thought was really
poignant because
is Barbie was nominated for best
picture and this tweet says you know
Barbie getting a nomination for best
picture but not best director is weird
cuz like no one walked away from that
movie thinking that was the best movie
of the year but everyone walked away
thinking that was so fun they should let
women direct big budget movies more
often so it's like actually making the
case like why would Barbie and sorry
that tweet is from show me the yams why
would Barbie really ever be best picture
like it's not oh it wasn't
thought-provoking age with the second
half of the tweet in the sense that
everyone thought like women should get
more big director but I don't agree with
the first part of the tweet I feel like
a lot of people walked away from that
movie being like that was the best movie
ever like not you and not Ben yeah
people like it changed
them I mean yeah I mean let's not get
into it let's not get into it and just
the other thought that I had I saw
someone like commented this under Ryan's
statement they were like okay so who in
the best actress category or shouldn't
be nominated then right and so a lot of
people saying this is like a snub to
women it wasn't like you know margar
Robbie didn't get nominated and amand
did instead it's a women's category
there two separate issu like Margot
Robbie not being nominated for best
actress isn't a SN for women because
another woman got that nomination so if
marar Robbie should have been nominated
then who shouldn't have been right who
would you take the nomination away from
who didn't deserve it right because her
movie wasn't about like Barbie feminism
not even that like which of the
actresses wasn't good enough and Margot
Robbie was better than them like name
names yeah we can't all be nominated
it's
true also like no one from killers of
the flower moon is putting a statement
out like this about Leo right right
right but there's like such like long
winded beef between Leo and because you
know what's so funny to me is I forget
you know on Tik Tok they do this thing
where they'll cut up a movie and post it
in 50 Parts 3 minutes each and you'll
watch a movie on Tik Tok and I guess the
recent movie that went viral was What's
Eating Gilbert Grape classic which if
you don't know is this old old movie
with Johnny Depp and Leonardo Dicaprio
and it's about this really poor family
who lives with their mom it's like a
bunch of siblings the mom is like 600b
and all the kids just pretty much spend
their days trying to take care of her
and the eldest son who's played by
Leonardo DiCaprio has autism and he's
like always getting themselves in these
situations and they don't really know
how to like handle him it's like it's an
amazing movie and Leonard DIC capio pays
this like autistic teenager and I I was
watching this clip of him at the dinner
table and the Leonardo's character
starts to have a breakdown and it was
the most really like amazing act I've
ever seen in my life I was like wow he
didn't even win an Oscar for that no
what's crazy is he's only won one Oscar
and it was probably from his most
forgettable movie was the Revenant when
he has been in so I mean Titanic Titanic
Wolf of Wall Street
Jango shall we count Catch Me If You Can
oh yeah um
Aviator really like blockbuster hits
that like people will watch for years
and years Inception it's my favorite
movie to shut Island Inception is my
favorite movie to reference that I've
never seen same shutter no your favorite
one is um sliding doors yes so much so
that I thought you saw it so I watched
it no no uh he doesn't deserve an Oscar
for this but Les we not forget Great
Gatsby he does not deserve an Oscar for
that I agree
Gangs of New York OJ no really like if
you've never seen what's eeden Gilbert
Grape I think it's Leonardo DiCaprio's
best work yeah and it's just like
weirdly star studded with Johnny Depp
he's so young and so hot like you never
saw someone so hot as like 20-year-old
Johnny up in this movie it's actually a
really sad movie like be prepared yeah
so you're right there is some sort of
beef between Leo and the Oscars right
which is why no one's like releasing a
statement and also he's a man so like
who cares right right no no no nobody
cares um
but Ryan gossing I feel like he had kind
of had to do yeah of course something
like that I'm sure he wanted to as
also yeah everyone's like it's literally
the plot of the movie coming true but
it's like it's really not because seven
other extremely talented women were
nominated and like you making it about
marar Robbie like does take it away the
accomplishment from those women so like
and it was nominated if it was s for
best picture like that would be crazy it
is kind of crazy she wasn't nominated
for best director I agree by the way
because Greta Gerwig is an amazing
director and I think she directed the
movie to Perfection she also like then
directed all the affiliate like music
videos and it all had this like really
cohesive look I agree I think Rea Gerwig
was snubbed more than Margo Robbie yes
um I agree best picture it's
like you know yeah it's not like a full
snubbing it's still one of the most
nominated but I don't know what it is
about the Barbie movie like it is a
polariz like the way the Oscars can't
release their nominations without it
becoming about the bar movie like people
the Barbie movie stands need to shut the
up they're pissing me off and
they're being insanely dramatic oh and I
said this on the patreon last night and
I actually thought it was like one of my
best points yet and I'd like to repeat
it if that's okay with you because I saw
this trending Tik Tok sound that was
like a mix of different audios but it
was basically the music instrumentally
from the Billy eish Barbie song so it's
like when did it end and then they start
playing America ferrera's like
Millennial woman feminist monologue that
everybody loved from the movie and then
they start mixing it with Joe ky's joke
about a plastic Barbie doll with boobies
and everybody's making these videos
about how hard it is to be a woman and
they're like doing their makeup and like
crying and I just really can't get over
the way like women have reacted to a
joke and the joke was bad and it was
offensive like I agreed like it was a
bad joke that was my first thought
you're not going to hear me defending
this joke but like our reaction to it
and I'm sorry not our cuz I would never
your reaction to it like really makes
you look so weak and you're like mad at
this joke that is like making women look
weak and then your reaction is making
you look like the biggest loser
like it's like almost justifying the
joke like stop like you don't if you
want people to respect women like stop
acting like that yeah no and to be
honest and that's not even like my usual
reflex when I heard that joke that was
like the first thing I said it's yikes
yikes misogynistic like the movie is so
much more than that like that's really
you can write any joke about the biggest
movie and that's the joke you write like
no but we like okay it's two weeks later
let's move on no and like we're still
we're making trending sounds and like
crying and like taking off our makeup
and like this is me it's just it's so
losery and it's such a bad way to
respond to like to a joke that everyone
agreed like Joe Quay got punished like
Joe Quay will never work in this town
again I saw joqui like doing an
interview it was so awkward I wanted to
die for him like he has been handled the
world handled him and so our reaction is
now to like just stay down stay down
like stop stop I can't with some of
these send me one of those next
time you see it no I just need to see it
okay our next story are you ready for it
mhm Megan Markle and Prince Harry
stepped out last night they made a
surprise red carpet appearance in
Jamaica wait I didn't see I feel like
every time they leave the house I see it
right they went to the Bob Marley movie
premiere in Jamaica so there's a new
movie about Bob Marley called Bob Marley
One Love and they walk the red carpet
hand in hand with Megan in a Black
Ensemble while Hari went for a suit
without a tie she looked amazing I'm
looking hold
on and she looks gorgeous yeah truly
truly uh the movie celebrates the life
and music of an icon who Inspire
Generations through his message of love
and unity also Megan and Prince Harry
posed with the CEO of Paramount Pictures
and Nickolodeon at the premiere oh they
got a big deal coming through it was
giving like that Lion King Premiere
where they're talking and Bob Iger I
feel like the deal you know Disney I
think ran its course Spotify and Netflix
and now they're taking their talents to
powermount like I it felt exactly like
that cuz really otherwise like what are
they doing at a movie premiere across
the hemisphere when there's movie
premieres in their backyard every day no
it's true there's definitely like some
big p partnership going or or Megan is
like really close with you know some of
the Marley family
relatives maybe that's the only thing I
can think of no I
not business related I think she was
there to support her friends I think
they've brought attention to this movie
that I previously hadn't heard of okay
and in exchange for some Goodwill on
that deal coming through with Paramount
plus so I'm glad you brought this up
because I actually want to talk about
this movie cuz I've seen like five
commercials for it and at first I was
like oh they're making like a rocket man
type of movie it's like the same exact
remember they copy and pasted Rocket Man
to Bohemian rap city Bohemian rap city
and now they're doing it for Bob Marley
I'm like oh this will be good I saw this
commercial I swear to God it was giving
parody like it looks so fake I can't
explain why like Community Theater Vibes
like wait let me look really quick I was
so confused like the accent was almost
like
patronizing and like
cliche tell me if you have the same
reaction while watching the
theater
are you getting the gist I'm getting the
gist yeah it does look like that same
sort of um template but you could tell
made for TV it kind of looks like a
lifetime biopic yeah you could tell the
scale of a movie like this by like how
big of a crowd they can get for like
those theater scenes like yeah um you
only see like maybe like a hundred
people in the crowd it's meant to be
like a bigger Arena but like when they
did Wembley Stadium for Bohemian rap
city like they were able to get to match
the scale of it there's not a lot of
scale here I would say yeah no the movie
looks like oddly lowbudget and so I was
kind of just like chalking it up to
being a TV movie but knowing that it's
like Paramount and that Megan and Harry
went to support it's obviously like this
big budget film and I just thought based
on the trailer I was like what is this
it looked like
crap no I was like honestly Bob Marley's
rolling over in his grave give him the
the Elton John treatment like he
deserves a better movie than this yeah I
wonder if it'll be in the theaters or
just no it's like literally it's a movie
movie no I think it's like in the
theaters it's a real movie well real
movies go onto streamers these days do
they Maestro but we decided that's not a
real movie right yeah okay well um I
just thought that was interesting that
they were out and about and that's where
they were and I just feel like we'll be
seeing them on Powerman plus soon that's
what I think y I agree are you ready for
our next story a little Jonas family
drama oh no uh Panka Chopra posted and
quickly deleted a picture from a double
date with Joe Jonas and his new flame
stormy brain what picture prianka posted
and then quickly deleted a photo from
what appeared to be a double date with
her brother-in-law Joe and his new flame
stormy Brie the snapshot which quickly
appeared on her Instagram story on
Monday showed Four Hands clinking
champagne flutes at a restaurant one
hand in the picture had the same tattoo
that the model has on her right hand
which was enough to convince fans that
Nick and prianka were spending time with
the rumored couple like these four
hanging out is like not shocking and no
sorry wait I want to restart my sentence
reset Joe having like a new girlfriend
like we know it's not like a big secret
it's not a big deal for me the most
shocking part of the story is that like
Nick and Joe are hanging out in their
private time like with their girlies
like I am like a conspiracy theorist and
I feel like these two hate each other
right so my biggest takea away from this
story is like oh no they're actually on
a double date like you wouldn't do that
with someone you like are dying to get
away from oh no I feel like they just
have like classic sibling especially
when it comes to the business like just
like sibling rivalry stuff but it makes
me feel like maybe there was I feel like
if prianka loves Sophie like she
wouldn't be like so quick with it it's
honestly I was thinking about that too
it's actually a really tough spot for
Priyanka to be in because I think she
did love Sophie and I think they're good
friends but like at the end of the day
like Nick is her family she's not going
to be she's got to move on with them
like she's got to stay with them like
that's family and you can stay in touch
of course but you're not going to be
best friends I know but like Sophie is
also family still like that's her
daughter's and a well true and he still
an aunt I think so okay and she is the
mother of priyanka's
nieces right
yeah that one they're still priyanka's
nieces because Joe is still her
brother-in-law the other one the other
one is a little more tenuous yeah yeah
okay yeah yeah yeah she's still the
mother of priyanka's nieces so she there
she's still family yeah like I think if
prianka like wanted to hang out with
Sophie still like that would it would be
fine it' be okay and I think it would be
kind of nice me too and she could still
get the kids together and by the way
I've never been like divorced but I
think for a lot of people who marry into
like big families and everyone's married
part like you st and if you love that
family it it keeps you married for
longer like you don't want to leave the
family and in-law the J sisters exactly
it it makes the whole marriage more fun
yeah a lot of people write into Deer
toasters that like they miss their
in-laws yeah so I think it's not so
quick to remove it but the fact that she
would post this maybe she just thought
she was posting like a cute picture and
was looking for content and like didn't
want to make herself the center of like
some thing when it was just not yeah
like she didn't even realize what she
was doing I could see that for pre
because she doesn't seem like so zeroed
in on social media like what does
everything mean all the time yeah no
she's like an older woman with kids and
a life like yeah and she just like posts
and doesn't think too much about it so I
don't think this like means that much
like she's anti Sophie or that like yeah
we don't Joe
are super serious I think she just made
a GAA so funny actually like ever since
stormy Breeze what's her name Brie
stormy Brie came into my life now on my
Tik Tok I guess like a lot of people
went searching for her ex Lucky Blue and
now Lucky Blue is with this new girl the
new lucky Blue's like new wife they make
a lot of content together she's all over
my Tik Tok now she basically is in her
kitchen in full Glam like looking so
gorgeous making the most delicious food
you've ever seen in your homestead style
she makes her own bread she makes her
own peanut butter and she makes her own
jelly yeah yeah I saw that yeah yeah
yeah she Homesteader love we love a
tradwife
yeah yeah and she's pregnant right yes
it's giving ballerina Farm yep are you
ready for our fifth and final story is
it the final story that's brought to you
by the farmer's dog
yes this new year the easiest healthy
Habit to start is one for your dog so
meet the farmer's
dog it makes feeding real healthy dog
food easy and convenient and your dog
will absolutely love it it's smart
healthy pet food that you can feel good
about feeding your pup and that's why
it's time to quit kibble kick the cans
and start fresh the farmer's dog makes
and delivers fresh healthy dog food
right to your door it's developed by
vets it's nutritionally balanced and
it's made from real meat and veggies to
the safety standards of human food it's
the best option for dogs at all life
stages because it's not kibble it's not
canned goo it's just real healthy food
traditional dry and wet dog food options
are highly processed they can use much
lower quality ingredients than they
claim to and they are extremely
difficult to portion accurately so the
farmer's dog isn't just fresh higher
quality food they also send the food
pre-portion specifically for your dog
based on their unique nutritional needs
makes it easy to help your dog maintain
their ideal weight which is one of the
biggest indicators of a full healthy
life dogs at healthy weight can live up
to 2 and half years longer than
overweight dogs a fresh diet has been
found to have all sorts of benefits from
healthier coat and skin to fresher
breath even digestion and smaller better
poops so it doesn't matter if your dog
is old or young it's always the right
time to begin investing in their health
and that means more happy healthy and
full years together get 50% off your
first box of fresh healthy food at
thefarmersdog.com toast plus you'll get
free shipping but only when you go to
thefarmersdog.com toast to get that 50%
off that's thefarmersdog.com
toast thank you
you our fifth and final Story Kathy
Hilton and her husband Rick have a once
a week date at the Cheesecake Factory I
thought you were going to say divorce oh
no that wouldn't be a fifth Story you
know it's going to be like some tabloid
nonsense yeah Kathy and Rick's go-to
date spot is surprisingly lowkey she
told page six that we go to The
Cheesecake Factory once a week he really
likes the chicken fetuccini alfredo and
then also the one that you dip with the
sauce she said all their food is good
food and she likes to order the meatloaf
she said where else can you get a
meatloaf Okay order the worst thing on
the menu go off Queen she loves their
meatloaf they go there once a week for
the meatloaf she said she doesn't
indulge in any of their Fame cheesecakes
and but she does enjoy their dessert
offerings okay by the way when she said
we like those little things that you dip
she's definitely talking about those
avocado wraps you know that everybody
loves oh is that it for sure what else
would it be I'm going need to I haven't
been to a Cheesecake Factory in so long
I don't even know what I like the one by
your house is I'm looking if there's one
by my house and it's so kid-friendly
like you I can not say one bad thing
about the Cheesecake Factory like they
have crayons high chairs like sippy cups
it's so kid-friendly I think I have to
go take the family you know who loves
she saake Factory our brother-in-law
Zach Shapiro he'll go with you anytime
Zach Shapiro just texted us you didn't
check your phone or did you something
really funny he said Taylor Swift just
met Jason Kelce last weekend that feels
fishy oh my God totally
agree no I love Shapiro like shap us
getting into sports is the best thing to
ever happen to Shapiro like him and I
are always sending each other now like
sports stuff like no but also like
Taylor Swift getting into football like
is also the best thing to happen to you
for Shapiro he's in your sphere and
you're in his I but also I saw fishy I'm
dying I saw a headline that actually
Taylor Swift like being in the football
world has brought a lot of fathers and
daughters together I saw that too
because they now like want to watch the
game with their dad that their dads are
watching and they like talk about it so
cute is that is really cute and really
beautiful so
sweet wait back to Cheesecake Factory
um I couldn't really say anything
negative about Cheesecake Factory even
if I wanted to I think it's the most
beautiful it's you see think Disney's
the most magical place on Earth go to
The Cheesecake Factory like you're going
to love it the food is Never Never B
I've been in my life but just not in a
long time no I know I just feel like we
had this conversation about the girl who
was mad about
the guy who was going to take her on a
date to The Cheesecake Factory remember
yeah you know what I'm talking about
sort of she went viral she went viral
for saying right like that's not a date
place right was taking her on her first
date to The Cheesecake Factory and she's
like absolutely not and it sparked this
debate online like is a Cheesecake
Factory acceptable what's not acceptable
yeah full bar romantic lighting you know
Mediterranean style Decor delicious food
a skinny delicious
menu amazing staff like delicious
dessert even though I never partake in
dessert ever because I don't like
cheesecake you don't like cheesecake
that is not surprising even though they
have like a regular dessert menu too
like a brownie but the thing with but if
it's if it's
a if it's a successful restaurant like
you should be full and you won't need
dessert the food is so nourishing and
delicious like by the time I'm done I
don't need more for sure I don't always
order dessert but like I I do need a
little something sweet after my meal
even if it's just a sucker from my bag
like I need to cap it off yeah so me and
my friends like from high school we try
to do dinner like once a month and we
always go to the same restaurant and
they for dessert obviously offer like
berries and fruit but it comes with
cream like whipped cream and let me tell
you it's the perfect Apper tee mhm or
sometimes the dessert from I don't need
a cake I don't need like a whole dessert
plate but like I need a a worther but
sometimes I I need a Hershey Kiss
sometimes I do need a whole cake and
places like the Cheesecake Factory I
just will never forget you know BJ's
Brew House I feel like it's a really
underrated or was it Yard House no it
was BJ's Brew House it's kind of like a
smaller chain similar to like uh
Applebees kind of but a little bit more
refined they have this dessert it's like
a cookie in a pan you know with an ice
cream on top skillet 10 out of 10 so
good that I need every time I'm also new
to Yard House yard house is not huge in
New York but I discovered it when I was
on tour for a lot of people it's like
their Cheesecake Factory I do think it's
kind of better um just cuz Cheesecake
Factory is like such a big company like
they have a little bit quality control
issue just yeah things get lost the
details Yard House I think is like still
at the level where like they're
maintaining some sort of quality control
and Ben and I went after my ski lesson
right and you order on iPads and let me
tell you and we happened to be there
5:00 so it was happy hour our food came
in 30 seconds we had like two drinks two
appetizers and two entrees for actually
$25 like it was really and they're known
for their beer they do these a yard was
it actually $25 yes maybe 30 because
everything with the appetizers and
drinks were all half off for happy hour
oh oh so we literally ended up only
paying for our Entre it was just like
Yard House doesn't get enough love No
Love No Love well that's what we're here
to do and we're also here to do deer
toasters our weekly advice segment wait
we're done with the stories yeah yeah
all done time to move on our weekly
advice segment where you can write into
us two people who you look up to and we
could literally give you advice on
what's going on in your life so you can
submit at dear toasters gmail.com that's
the email account dear toasters
gmail.com we'll keep your Anonymous
don't worry and you could write in about
anything from work stuff to relationship
stuff to finance stuff we actually
recently had a lot of Finance ones I
guess it's q1 people are trying to get
organized for the year so here are our
submissions you ready mhm hi ladies
here's the thing my boyfriend is 36 and
he's been getting Botox in his forehead
for several years is it just me or does
this seem a little self-involved for a
guy the men in my family couldn't be
further from the botox type so it is a
little strange to me that my boyfriend
gets shot up more than I do he also
tries to hide it from me along with a
lot of other things he has hidden for me
over the years
thoughts well we can get into the
botoxing but I just want to say based on
your inquiry I feel like you don't trust
your boyfriend like what else is he
hiding from you lying is weird by the
way yeah lying is always weird yep cuz
Botox is not like the biggest thing in
the world your face relatively looks the
same oh yeah but it is like a little
self- indulge for a man to do not like
it's giving Tom sand ofal yeah that's
exactly what it's giving like shaving
your forehead taking more time to get
ready than your girlfriend like there
are metrosexual men who are very
concerned with their appearance it
doesn't bother me I don't know if I
would find it attractive but that's like
a personal thing but there seems to be
like an underlying issue here with this
dude that like he hide stuff from you
yeah but I I could see getting theck
from a man getting Botox no for sure
especially at 36 where it's like those
lines are like that's a good age you
know maybe later in life I it would be
more understandable but like 36y old man
getting Botox like is Icky yeah and it's
so different cuz like honestly we live
in a world where like the older man gets
if he's like good-looking like he just
gets more and more good-looking like I
really believe that so what are you
doing yeah like you've been given a gift
and honestly this makes me my red flag
here is not that he gets Botox is that
he obviously has very poor judgment like
you've been given a gift and you're
taking a dump on it yeah yeah I don't
like it I don't like it either but
honestly wake up with your
boyfriend y cuz I'm
bored okay next up I actually really
like this one another a little Finance
Hey sisters I'm having a major SOS I got
married a little over a year ago and
I've started to realize that my
husband's mother watches over every
Financial move we make my husband's
family is pretty well off and I'm the
luckiest of the lucky to say that I get
to be a stay-at-home mom because of that
but my mother-in-law apparently has all
of our financial information at hand I'm
really starting to have an issue with
the lack of shall I say privacy we can
barely buy new furniture or a weekend
trip without myself or my husband
getting a text or call asking what we
bought I know I should be grateful for
the money that we have but am I wrong
for feeling weird about the fact that
she knows everything about my life
financially you're not wrong for like
feeling weird that's a a tough spot to
be in but like money comes with strings
this is the price you pay this is the
price you pay would you rather have
complete privacy and no furniture or a
lack of privacy and gorgeous Furniture
yeah and it's not like she's stopping
you from buying these things she just
like wants full transparency and like
and she wants to give you a pit she
wants you to know that she's watching
money like that's what it means yeah
people there's no such thing as a free
lunch no and also like marrying into a
wealthy family like could go many
different ways this isn't the worst one
like they're generous but they're
cautious no it doesn't even sound like
cautious she just curious yeah she's
like annoying about it but you still are
getting you still are getting the things
that you want and you're living the life
that you want in your stay-at home mom
so like that's what it means I think
maybe work on like you can't control her
so maybe control how you are going to
react to it try not to let it bother you
yeah if you just like accept it and May
and and be like this is how it's going
to be does it change what you buy like
is she putting like limitations on what
you can buy or you just have to like run
them by her just you have to justify it
yeah but like okay that's your job you
know yeah and I think it's it's really
like the price
of gold like yeah that's the job that's
how you earn the money yeah that's the
job
yeah like you feel uncomfortable but you
know what how's that new couch you
loving it yeah just take the call from
your new couch there's no such thing is
a free couch so in terms of what you'd
have to be giving up for that couch this
isn't the worst thing in the world I
know there are definitely in-laws who do
worst things there's no such thing as a
free anything yeah so cuz think about it
it's bothering you so much to the point
where you don't want to accept the money
anymore right until you get to that
point it might and at that point you do
what's best for you and your family but
until that point like ride that gravy
train totally send send those emojis H
new couch send a pick of you on the
couch thanks Gran love the
couch it's not the worst thing in the
world no it's not and nothing in life is
just like perfect and easy and if this
is what's going on you'll be you'll be
fine this is another third and final
submission that's also finance and I
thought it was interesting last year my
boyfriend of 5 years gave me his credit
card information and during my solo trip
to Europe this year I used it without
his knowledge to book tours and dinners
I should note he is a Millionaire right
love that for you it sounds like one of
my
novels I later went to far by booking a
flight resulting in his team reporting
fraud to the bank should I confess or or
continue without admitting my actions
I'm seeking advice on how to handle the
situation o the thing is I'm like all
for like running a man for every penny
he has like this like lowkey is stealing
like he gave you his credit card
information out of the goodness of his
heart like you a year later using it for
something that you he that you just
didn't even run by him like it's not
cool no it's not stealing like the
question is should you be honest that oh
that wasn't fraud that was me but it
might jeopardize your use of the card or
continue on your Merry way
and there's other charges like his team
sees those other things so like there's
an awareness that you're using the card
is there cuz he gave it to her a year
ago and she used it when he gave it to
her and now a year later used it on her
trip no but I think yeah but just the
one thing got
flagged yeah the book tour the the tours
and the dinners went unnoticed by his
team yeah so his team could think like
he's going to dinner but I guess the
flight maybe she flew herself first
class a little too much and that they
reported to the bank as fraud I think
that you should be honest one so that he
doesn't like go and change all of his
cards but also like so that he knows
that you're using his card and you want
to feel good about it like you obviously
he's generous so why don't you just like
learn what what's okay and what's not
okay yeah learn where the limit is yeah
like learn because you know you used it
last year and then you waited a whole
year maybe he's okay with you like going
out to dinner with your friends and
using it like let what what are his
limit also you don't want to run this
man dry like maybe he doesn't have as
much money as you think he does like
find out what he's comfortable with like
this was long overdue when he gave you
the information you should have had a
conversation about what exactly you're
allowed to do with it yeah no but you
could also trial find out TR uh trial by
fire yeah learn on the job I think that
if you want the relationship to be
successful like you have to be honest
and like you can't have this much like
deception and you aren't trying to like
Swindle him so you should tell him oh
that wasn't fraud that was me see his
reaction no and you do want this
relationship to be successful he's a
millionaire and it's you've been
together 5 years so you should have
honesty yeah and I I think you'll be
more
surprised with his generosity if you're
honest like getting caught in the lie
like that's going to make him like icky
she's using me yeah but you just being
totally upfront be like no I used the
credit card you gave me last year what's
the problem like you being more upfront
about it will make you look more normal
first of all and second of all I do
think you'll end up with more money from
him I think it will engender trust I
agree good but getting caught in a lie
about money you're in trouble yeah no
it's a bad path to go down where you're
just like being shady with someone
else's money like and this is the person
that you love don't do it don't do it
don't drop the ball here I'm rooting for
you um I'm rooting for you don't sign a
PR up so that's our show hope everybody
enjoyed it I know I did I did as well
tomorrow jackon and I are back same old
thing even though today's Friday but
then for the real Friday of this week we
will be audio only because I'm headed to
Fort Worth for the rodeo good times so I
will be podcasting from Fort Worth so
Audio Only just wanted to remind
everyone of that thank you so much for
listening to the toasta londay morning
show we the past five stories you need
to know every Monday through Friday on
YouTube so you're watching us on YouTube
please to subscribe and give this video
a thumbs up we're also available as
podcast and podcast can be found so
sptify
A beautiful setting and wly talented we
are love you okay
bye